[music]
Hi, I'm Tina Hesman Saey.
I'm the molecular biology reporter
for Science News magazine.
CRISPR is a hot new molecular biology tool,
that you may have heard of,
because everybody is using it to edit genomes,
to fix genes, and break genes,
and do all kinds of things.
CRISPR started out as a bacterial defense system
that sniffs out viruses
and chops them up into little pieces.
But some very clever scientists have re-engineered
the molecule so you can search out specific genes
and change them.
According to most scientists CRISPR can do anything,
but that's not exactly true, but it can do a lot of stuff.
They've already used it
to create more muscular beagles,
to repaint the wings on butterflies,
to create a mushroom
that doesn't brown when you cut it
and even to re-engineer some immune cells
so they will go and kill tumor cells in cancer.
So CRISPR is currently mostly a research tool,
but it's starting to get into helping people.
In 2017, you can expect, for instance,
to see clinical trials for cancer starting out with CRISPR.
And also, possibly, bringing CRISPR back to its roots
to combat viruses like HIV and hepatitis.
There's a question about whether
using CRISPR is ethical in a lot of different situations.
On the one hand you have the problem of
engineering designer babies perhaps,
by changing their genes with CRISPR.
And a lot of people are really uncomfortable with that.
But even if you just limit it to curing diseases,
for instance, some people may not be able
to afford a CRISPR therapy.
So you have to decide who should have access,
how much should it cost.
A lot of my beat is concerned with...
on the one hand we can do all these incredible things
with tools like CRISPR,
but on the other hand should we really do them?
[music]